in order to belong into this in this
tribe you have to conform and if you
have doubts your dangerous person how
many leaders have been built up in these
megachurches that fall because the
pressure is just too much and as I look
back we were two kids like trying so
hard to get it right my name is Lisa
Hunger a recent author I'm a musician
and a songwriter my mom and I found this
wild church they called themselves the
holy brothers and from the moment you
walked in it was loud people were like
running around the church I just think
it's awesome so while a lot of people
think it's crazy filled with crazy
people I loved it and I was in I ended
up going to college and I start dating
this boy who's like super Christian we
get married really we're too young to
even rent a car when we're marriage I
didn't drink or cuss so we end up
getting a job and a really big Church in
Michigan and this church was the size of
a mall I mean it's huge there's about
10,000 people we built the house out the
country they paid for our car for our
gas they paid from Michael's school we
were 20 years old and we had this this
dream job we don't have sex with each
other before we were married we waited
to kiss we did it all right we had this
transactional idea of God and that's why
we landed this really great awesome job
we started trying to get pregnant and
you couldn't get pregnant and people
would tell me well just pray and believe
like just say it and it will happen I
thought I just don't know how that can
be true we were traveling the world
we're going overseas and playing -
sometimes 60,000 people in arenas the
more we ran into other people's stories
but the more we started doubting what
we've been given a mic when I took this
trip in Europe from Rome we took trains
up to Cracow we visited the
concentration camps
we walk through the crematoriums and
it's real hard to come back to America
and pray for something when you have
these images of people's hair in piles
and children's shoes and piles your
ideas on what a good God is can change
pretty dramatically so I came back and
found myself trying to pray for us to
have a baby or pray for our church or
pray for these different things and I
just kept thinking about the
concentration camp and how my whole
perspective on my faith has been a
transaction if I'm good enough for if I
pray enough if I believe enough then I
get blessings and I get a baby or a good
life
it's not how life is we all have this
perspective on who was in and who was
out for Michael and I that began to
change slowly you have to conform and if
you have doubts
you're a dangerous person I remember
looking around going what am I doing
here what am i building with my life we
realized we're no good
for this place that we're at because our
ideas have changed so much and that we
needed to leave I had started weeping
and cried and freaking out like what are
we doing we don't know what we're doing
do you realize what we just left like we
left all of our security and we started
becoming heretics you know we go to
Denver we end up starting a little house
Church in our apartment our whole goal
for it was that it was inclusive and
that it was vulnerable and that it was
this place that we had always dreamed of
Church being more questions and more
doubt were arising for Michael and I are
like heretic levels kept like shifting
and change even like kind of one up in
each other yeah eventually Michael and I
would get pregnant and I was really glad
for that because it didn't feel like our
daughter was this answer right like we
really went through this trial and this
suffering and now we're getting this
baby girl our ideas of God or
deconstructing what is it that we still
believe but Michael looks at me and says
I I don't believe in God anymore like I
can't believe any of it and he just ends
up like talking more and I I remember
just like freezing in my whole body
because it there's always been I was
okay with the questions but I wasn't
okay with with that I ended up getting
pregnant again and we go through a whole
tour with me being pregnant and for
Michael he feels all this freedom in
atheism because he's not struggling
anymore
for me I'm filling all this anxiety
because I want him to believe a certain
thing and I want myself to believe a
certain
and we're and I'm still just struggling
hard to belong and to be okay and I had
ended up having to quit too early
because I'm having that our baby's
having difficulty growing she's born a
month and a half early she is just
beautiful and like with our first
daughter we're both crying it's just
this beautiful beautiful moment and and
then she turns blue
I remember this nurse coming over she's
like shaking and looking really worried
and she tells us our daughter has Down
syndrome and so in the days that follow
we find out that Lucy has two heart
issues and she has to have heart surgery
that her second day of life and then she
has to have another heart surgery and
she's six months old
everything really changed for me so I
feel like this story that I've been
living my whole life kind of came to
this climax with Lucy's birth when Lucy
was born we had this huge social media
blow up and there's stories and
magazines and all over the internet
about our heresy and we were completely
pushed out of the church world of this
tribe that we really loved and really
painful and devastated miss so many
times looking back on all of it I'm
deeply grateful for all of the things
that happen and I don't want what we
used to have we live in a different
headspace now it's a completely
different perspective and the the
connection I feel with my daughter's
there's no us versus them there's no you
and I there's no winners and losers
part of my dream is that people wouldn't
be so afraid and so scared I know a lot
of people are still in this very
conservative fundamental bubble and and
they can be so afraid to break out of
that from the fear of what will happen
to their lives and this can this happens
in any religion so my dream is that
we're not so afraid
[Music]
hey guys do you know what's Hispanic
Heritage Month nobody you from more
Latino content who's right here